that's my baby new memo from the
Minnesota Vikings to the Minnesota
Timberwolves versus the Lakers lizzo
mater presents well known at Sunday
night's game Webber on time yeah
Liz Oh was sitting courtside at the NBA
game chatting with her friend having a
drink enjoying snacks documenting the
game to her own Instagram but Liz o
couldn't contain her juice as she got
down to the Laker Girls performance of
her hit single y'all bout to see some
real happen
[Music]
and she had a lot of people talking
unfortunately some people on Twitter
weren't so happy she chose to show so
much of herself but honestly this isn't
the first time lizzo has showed off her
assets and remember this
anyways lizzo seemed to be enjoying
herself even giving a quick interview
revealing she's got her eye on a certain
player who are you cheering for tonight
in this basketball game
I mean tell you something both teams are
great I'm personally cheering for number
32 karl-anthony towns mr. gun that's my
baby she even changed up her famous
truth hurts lyric
it was a busy weekend for lizzo who also
took the stage at Jingle Ball
[Music]
she also just launched a brand-new good
as hell music video but back to Liz O's
courtside situation I'm still sweating
Europe are we surprised Liz oh is all
about feeling herself and doing her own
thing
you know I keeps it real alright guys
that's it for today what did you think
of Liz those Laker game dancing and
fashion let me know and for all the
latest on Liz oh and other fun viral
moments stick with all things et until
next time I'm Katie Krause and bye for
now
[Music]